5 millions de Français achètent sur
internet un chiffre en augmentation mais
certains consommateurs résitent encore
par porort de laisser leur numéro de
carte bleue alors une société a trouvé
la parade grâce à une carte virtuelle
pegy leuroi Guillaume
Michel des livres des couches de
l'alimentaire des voyages aujourd'hui
sur Internet tout se vend tout
s'achachète depuis sa chambre Boris
Mercier décide d'envoyer un bouquet à sa
maman il fait son choix mais au moment
de payer il ne donne plus son numéro de
carte bleue trop risqué il se connecte
sur ce logiciel fourni par sa banque il
rentre un numéro identifiant et un mot
de passe en quelques secondes une carte
bleue virtuelle s'affiche avec à chaque
fois un nouveau numéro valable pour un
seul achat un système qui rassure les
internautes acheter à l'étranger mettre
son numéro de carte sur un site qu'on
connaît pas c'est loin on sait pas on
sait pas forcément ce qui va se passer
alors que là bon il y a pas de problème
la carte virtuelle est-elle vraiment
sûre pas évident nous sommes allés poser
la question à la h Academy un journal
écrit par des jeunes spécialisés en
sécurité informatique écoutez bien vous
n'allez rien comprendre je suis pas
certain que ce soit le P entier qui soit
justement mis en en fait et dans ce CASL
il fallir patcher pour que ce soit le PA
entier selon ses surdoué tant qu'il
faudra s'identifier pour acheter sur
internet même par le biais d'un mot de
passe les fraudeurs trouveront des
failles la solution parfaite reste à
inventer
on travaille notamment sur des systèmes
d'authentification direct par lesquels
on insérera sa carte sa carte bleue
directement dans l'ordinateur ce qui
pourra être une véritable amélioration
du point de vue de la sécurité vous par
exemple vous payez sur internet avec
votre carte bleu moi non non non jamais
jamais les numéros de cte provisoires
constituent quand même un progrès en
matière d'achat sécurisé mais pour
dépenser sans crainte des pirates de
l'informatique la seule solution c'est
peut-être du shopping dans un vrai
magasin